Speaker 1: Welcome back to the show. I am Jessie
Dollar Moore standing in sitting in, actually,
as you can see, sitting in for David Pakman while
he is away. Listen. Over the course of the first
few days of the year when Congress was coming in
and the new majority of Republicans took over,
we witnessed the absolute debacle that was the
election of Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the
House. The 15 votes that it took, the day upon
day upon day of trying to find out who was going
to be speaker of the House of Representatives. And
Matt Gates led the effort, Matt Gates and Lauren
Boebert and Chip Roy. There was a few bad actors,
although it is kind of a lesson in the enemy of my
enemy can also be my friend, even though they're
certainly not friends. It was all chaotic and,
you know, kind of entertaining to watch. A lot
of people will say that, oh, it was bad for the
institution and all of that. And I don't really
take part in all of that. The more disorganized
they are, the better it is for the country
because the little damage they're able to do.
But Matt Gates was one of these ringleaders
here in this. And Ari MELBER, I don't know why,
but Ari MELBER had Matt Gaetz on his show to talk
about this, and they spent a lot of time. And this
is the reason. Listen, I'm not going to say be so
critical that I would say you shouldn't have him
on your show, but what good does it do? You're
not going to get to the truth if you ask him
questions. Matt Gaetz is going to systematically
lie to you right to your face over and over and
over. In classic Matt Gaetz Republican fashion.
So I don't understand it. But he was there and we
need to talk about it. He was asked specifically
about what secret deal was made with McCarthy to
actually get him the votes to become speaker.
There's obviously a mini page 40 page document
outlining the rules and going forward some of
the procedures that will govern this particular
Congress. But there was also like a three or four
page document that's in secret that no one knows
the contents of of exactly what was negotiated.
And this is important for a number of different
reasons. One, mainly because of the hypocrisy of
the Republican Party in this particular flavor
of Republican that acts like transparency in
government is what we should be going for when in
actuality they're not interested in that at all.
Watch this appearance by Matt Gaetz on MMS, NBC.
Speaker 2: Oh, you mentioned personnel. That
is something that has been reportedly written
down and agreed to on the side, a sort of a side
deal. Here's Congresswoman Mace on some of that.
Speaker 3: I don't know what they got or
didn't get. We haven't seen it. We don't
have any idea what promises were made or
what gentlemen's handshakes were made.
Speaker 2: Let's get into this. Maybe we
resolve it once and for all right. Here on
live TV. You have a 55 page rules package. That
part is public. Under the rules, we could put
up reporting on that. We all know about that.
Then you have reporting of a secret three page
agreement reading here from Punchbowl. McCarthy
and his allies hash this out with the Freedom
Caucus. It's got the other concessions, including
Rules Committee. That's personnel, I believe,
what you just referred to and other things. Point
blank, Congressman, have you or your staff seen
this additional agreement in writing in any form?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it took multiple forms. There was
specifically a side by side sheet where we made
offers to McCarthy. There were some offers. He
accepted some, he modified. Some he rejected,
just like you'd see in any negotiation. I can
tell you that Thomas Massie, Chip Roy, Ralph
Norman being on the Rules Committee would not
have happened. But for this negotiation, folks
like Representative Clyde, Representative Cloud,
two great conservatives on the Appropriations
Committee, that's a direct result of these
negotiations. This week, we'll be voting on
Paul Gosar as legislation to end the COVID
national emergency. That was a piece of pie.
Speaker 2: So the McCarthy kind of I'll let
you continue, but the question where
I'm going is, why keep that secret?
Speaker 4: I'm what are your questions? I'm happy
to tell you any element. I'm actually quite proud
of the word product. So it's no secret at all.
Speaker 2: The product, though, I appreciate you
here taking questions, but why not release
the written product that it exists and it's
currently been kept secret. And for context,
you and others have talked about bringing
transparency to government. It's one thing
to hear it described and another thing for
the government. Now, the House Republican
majority to just release whatever this
underlying material is. Here's a little bit
of how you and some others have sounded about
government secrecy.
Speaker 1:
The American people are tired of the swamp games.
Speaker 4: We had the audacity to want
to know what in the world was
going on behind closed doors.
Speaker 2: Why not commit to releasing the written
agreement or working to get it released tonight?
Speaker 4: I have no objection to that.
Speaker 1: That's what I'm talking about.
There's no answers there. Well, we agreed to
some things. Some things were agreed to. Other
things were not agreed to. There you go. All
transparent. I don't know that there was any
efficacy that nothing was gained from this other
than, yeah, he's a liar and we know he's a liar.
What we do know, though, is that Kevin McCarthy
did make a deal. And as a result of that deal,
some of those names that he mentioned and he
rattled off very quickly, there's some of the
most radical in the Congress, Thomas Massie. Him
and his family taking pictures with their teens.
Lauren Boebert on on very important committees on
the House Oversight and Accountability Committee.
Paul Gosar is on that committee. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is on that committee. Not only is Marjorie
Taylor GREENE on that committee. She's on Homeland
Security. She's on the COVID Origins Committee.
All of this should bring alarm bells ringing in
your head about what kind of dirty, dark room,
backroom deals Kevin McCarthy made with these
maniacs. Andrew Clyde. The man who said that
the insurrection against the United States of
America was just like a normal tourist visit.
Chip Roy, Ted Cruz's former chief of staff.
This is where we are in our Congress. This is
our calling. They act like they want to get so
much things done. Yet they're all they're going
to be doing is focused on investigations. They're
not going to work with the Biden administration
to pass anything useful or reasonable for the
American people, because that's not on the agenda.
Owning the libs is on the agenda. Cruelty is on
the agenda. Because they know, look, they'll
they're going to pass bills and brag about the
bills they passed that are going to be radical
in nature that have no chance of even getting
through the Senate. Not to mention getting to the
president's desk for a signature. We need to play
for them the I'm just the bill. Yeah, I'm only
a bill that. The Schoolhouse Rock to reeducate
them on how a bill is made. That their role as
legislators is to write and pass legislation for
the express purpose of getting to the President's
desk for signature. Instead, this is what we get.
Very disheartening.